in der fachsprache wird das mysteriöse
gigantische nichts im all lokale lehre
genannt die riesige zone kosmische
nichts liegt direkt in unserer
nachbarschaft obwohl sie schon 187
aufgespürt werden konnte stellt sie für
fachleute weltweit ein riesiges rätsel
dar
doch jetzt ist es einem hawaiianischen
forschungsteam gelungen diese materie
emotionen zu kartieren
ein spektakulärer erfolg der unter
anderem zeigt dass diese lokale lehre
einen entscheidenden einfluss auf die
bewegung der milchstraße hat klick zum
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
und aufstellung bekommt ihr die videos
übrigens werbefrei und vor allen anderen
der link ist hier unter me und in der
video beschreibung über die sogenannte
lokale lehre die auch als lokaler beugt
bezeichnet wird und einfach ein riesiges
nichts in der nähe unserer galaxie
darstellt wissen forschungsteams
weltweit bislang kaum etwas und das
obwohl diese materie arme lücke im all
bereits vor 32 jahren 1987 aufgespürt
werden konnte klar ist dass ein netz von
großräumigen strukturen die verteilung
von materie im universum prägt es gibt
mehrere bereiche aber außerdem auch
dichte filamente und große klumpen von
galaxien und gas heißt also im klartext
galaxien sind alles andere als
gleichmäßig verteilt stattdessen bilden
sie cluster und so befinden sich
zwischen ihnen lehrräume ein teil dieser
großen struktur ist der sogenannte la
negra super cluster er beherbergt rund
100.000 galaxien darin enthalten ist
nicht nur der bürger galaxienhaufen
sondern auch die lokale gruppe dessen
größten galaxien sind die milchstraße
und die andromeda-galaxie als weiteren
teil enthält der la negra superklasse
aber eben auch noch den lokalen wollt
also die lehre zone die sich im weltall
tatsächlich in unserer unmittelbaren
nachbarschaft befindet und direkt am
rand der lokalen gruppe beginnt von der
erde aus gesehen erstreckt sich das
gigantische nichts über 40% des himmels
also fast die hälfte
nach den schätzungen von fachleuten
dürfte der durchmesser der lokalen lehre
mindestens 150 millionen lichtjahre
betragen dazu der astronomen brennt alle
unsere beziehung zu dieser struktur ist
daher fundamental um die details
zur kosmischen nachbarschaft zu
verstehen entscheidend ist nämlich dass
die materie aus der der rest der lokalen
gruppe und eben auch die milchstraße
gebildet wird wohl aus der lokalen lehre
stammt erkenntnisse in diesem
zusammenhang könnten also dazu beitragen
die entstehung unserer galaxie besser
nachvollziehen zu können und vielleicht
sogar das große rätsel dem mysteriösen
dunklen materie zu lösen
doch obwohl diese riesige lücke im all
wirklich enorm ist ist es
forschungsteams weltweit bislang nicht
gelungen mehr über diese lokale lehre
herauszufinden weder seine struktur form
oder größe sind bekannt dazu teile der
beute ist so groß dass er auf beiden
seiten weit über die galaktische ebene
hinausragt dennoch ist ein großer teil
von ihm verdeckt die sicht auf die
lokale lehre ist von uns aus gesehen
also verdeckt weil sie sich hinter der
zentralen masse unserer galaxie befindet
und so ist die aktuelle studie ein
riesiger erfolg denn den fachleuten ist
es tatsächlich gelungen die lokale lehre
mit hilfe eines astronomischen
datensatzes zu kartieren sie haben quasi
hinter unsere galaxie gesehen dazu
analysierten sie die bewegungen von rund
18.000 galaxien unter berücksichtigung
der galaxie bewegung konnte so eine 3d
karte unserer kosmischen nachbarschaft
erstellt werden mit der die materie
verteilung nachvollzogen werden kann
diesen analysen zufolge besteht die
lokale lehre aus mehreren unter
bereichen die wirklich extrem leer sind
der lokale wollte um fast im gesamten
einen raum bereich von unglaublichen
200.000 kubikmeter 66 steht übrigens für
parallax second und ist ein
astronomisches längenmaß ein paar sec
entspricht etwa 3,26 lichtjahre und noch
mehr die lokale lehrer ist
offensichtlich teil eines netzes aus
kosmischen bolz denn sie scheint mit
zwei noch größeren bolz verbunden zu
sein
durchaus überrascht ist das
forschungsteam von der erkenntnis dass
die lokale gruppe und die milchstraße zu
einer materie brücke gehören die sich
quer durch diese lokale lehre zieht dazu
heißt es in der studie
ein sehr dünnes filament reicht vom
bürger cluster zum perseus cluster und
überspannt dabei auf dramatische weise
ein tiefes minimum dem lokalen wollt den
beginn dieses filaments bildet die
lokale schicht die auch die milchstraße
umfasst heißt also im klartext unsere
galaxie befindet
sich auf einer schmalen materie brücke
die sich durch die lokale lehre zieht
diese dünne brücke umfasst eine ganze
kette von galaxien und zieht durch die
erste stelle der lokalen lehre dazu dass
astronomie team wir leben direkt am rand
einer lehre eine erkenntnis die wirklich
folgenreich ist denn die gigantische
lücke beeinflusst die bewegung der
milchstraße in großem ausmaß mit bis zu
250 kilometern pro sekunde wird unsere
heimat galaxie von ihr weg gestoßen
die lokale lehre wirkt also als
abstoßender pohl die fachleute vermuten
jetzt dass es sich bei dieser lücke um
den sogenannten die propeller handelt
diese abstoßende pohl im kosmos wurde
vor einigen jahren aufgespürt damals wo
die vermutung aufgestellt dass er
verantwortlich für die bewegung unserer
milchstraße ist die aktuelle studie legt
jetzt nahe dass die lokale lehre
zusammen mit der anziehenden wirkungen
des virgo super clusters und die hälfte
der relativen bewegungen unserer galaxie
bewirbt das könnte also einen hinweis
auf ein großes ungelöstes rätsel der
astronomie sein forschungsteam weltweit
tüfteln schon seit langer zeit daran
warum die bewegung der andromeda galaxie
der milchstraße und anderen benachbarten
kleineren galaxien so sind wie sie eben
sind deren geschwindigkeiten weichen
nämlich 600 kilometer pro sekunde von
der allgemeinen
expansionsgeschwindigkeit des universums
ab somit ist also nicht nur die gesamte
expansion des universums entscheiden für
die bewegung von galaxien auch die
schwerkraft der nachbarn spielt eine
entscheidende rolle so bewegen sich
galaxien hin zur dichterin regionen des
universums und weg von leeren räumen
eine folge davon
die lehrräume werden immer größer ist ja
auch logisch gravitation führt zur
verdichtung von materie lehrer bereiche
müssen also immer leerer werden gibt es
beweise für ein paralleluniversum
megacool das video von marius
angeschrien unbedingt hier anklicken
anschauen und marius angeschrien
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran